ماذا عن عندما آخذ طفلي البالغ من العمر ثلاث سنوات
إلى مرحلة ما قبل المدرسة عند التكبير '' إذا رأت أن كل
أصدقائها آمن أو
يمكن لأشخاص آخرين التجسس عليه ، فهذا يعني أن
كونيكتيكت محض تأكد ولكنك تقوم
بتمكين كلمة مرور وتأكد من أن الآخرين  لذلك
لا يمكنهم معرفة اجتماع نافذة المشي لمسافات طويلة
والتأكد من تمكين
قاعدة الاجتماع ، يمكننا القيام بميزة أعتقد
أنها تتوفر على الرغم من جمال ميزة الأمان
ومع ذلك نحتاج إلى التركيز على
التعليم ، يجب علينا فرض هذه
الإعدادات لـ unis الجديدة تمامًا
خاصة بالنسبة للمستهلكين وهذا ما
فعلناه مؤخرًا ، ما هي
أكثر استخدامات التكبير / التصغير إثارة للاهتمام التي
رأيتها في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية
بالنسبة لي ، هذه الخدمات الدينية
اليوم هي عيد الفصح الذي يصادف يوم الأحد
رمضان في وقت لاحق من شهر
أبريل  ونرى العديد من
دور العبادة تقدم خدمات على Zoom ، نعم
هذا صحيح ، لقد تلقينا الكثير منكم
يعرفون قبلات مستخدم جديد ، هذه واحدة منهم
مثل ساعة سعيدة أيضًا وجميع أنواع
حالات المستخدمين الجدد.  لكن قاعدة المستخدمين
محددة جدًا ، لذا كيف أصبح
عملاء المؤسسات التقليدية الذين تعرفهم
أيضًا
عملاء مؤسسيين ، قال مجلس
التعليم في مدينة نيويورك إنه لن
تستخدم المدارس ميزة التكبير / التصغير نظرًا للمخاوف
المتعلقة بالخصوصية والأمان التي
ترى الكثير منها  تلك الحالات التي
يتراجع فيها الأشخاص فجأة ولا
يستخدمون النظام الأساسي ، لا تعرف في الواقع
أننا ما زلنا في طور العمل
مع مدارس نيويورك الجيدة في نيويورك
لأنهم يقدرون حقًا
القيام بذلك ، لذا تأكد من أننا
نعلم بالفعل  فرض تنفيذ
الإعدادات الأمنية المختلطة ، لن يحدث قصف بوبي
مرة أخرى أثناء القيام
بالعملية للعمل معهم ، لذا
فأنت تعمل على ذلك.
خطوات خاطئة على مدار الأسابيع الماضية
وصورتنا جيدة الآن نتعلم
الدرس ونقوم بتثبيته في
الخصوصية والأمان قبل أن نفعل
أي شيء نحتاجه  فكر في ذلك في
نيفادا فقط
لأنك تهتم بخدمة العملاء عندما
تتراجع خطوة إلى الوراء ، ركز على الخصوصية والأمان الذي
نريد القيام به لنكون أمان الخصوصية
عبر الشركة